i want to talk about uh a bit of news
from a few days ago which is quite
interesting there is now a report that
president joe biden told former
president barack obama
that he is going to run in 2024 that joe
biden will run for re-election in 2024.
there's a report in the guardian from a
few days ago
which has a sub-headline the president
joe biden thinks he's the only one who
can beat trump according to what a
source told the hill as trump readies
his own third run the article reads joe
biden has told barack obama he will run
for re-election in 2024 according to
washington website the hill
the site cited two anonymous sources one
was quoted as saying biden wants to run
and he's clearly letting everyone know
it wasn't clear when biden told obama
his plan but obama did visit the white
house earlier this month to celebrate
the affordable care act
we know that
joe biden used to be the vice president
at 78 biden was the oldest president
ever inaugurated if he won again he
would be 82 at the start of a second
term
in september it was widely reported
biden and aids told allies he planned to
run again in december biden said he
would run if he stayed in good health
he also said kamala harris his vp would
be on the ticket again
in a december interview with abc biden
said another trump candidacy would
increase the prospect of running
in brussels in march
biden referred to trump when he said in
the next election i'd be very fortunate
if i had the same man running against me
do i think joe biden is going to run
again i actually don't know i
at this point
i believe that joe biden has to say
it is my intention to run for reelection
i i don't have any doubt that that is
the correct thing to say it would be
problematic for his presidency now to
say i'm not even going to run again it
would be an a news cycle a serious news
cycle
it would interfere with whatever it is
joe biden
plans to try to do and what's left of
his first term so i think that no matter
what his intentions are this is what he
would be saying right now whether he
will ultimately run i don't know
now the question of who could beat trump
we actually do have some polling and i
know that looking at polling this early
is a bit fraught but we have a number of
different uh polls which um
can give us some information many of
these are from the last few days in a
hypothetical biden versus trump matchup
the morning consult politico poll has
biden 45 and trump 44.
now
you could argue that's not great because
trump isn't even really a candidate you
could also say trump really kind of is a
candidate because everybody thinks he's
running in an insider advantage poll
a trump is defeating biden 4743
there's a yougov yahoo news poll where
it's biden 43 trump 41
um and then there's also other polls
like bernie vs trump where trump bests
bernie by one in morning consult so i
don't know
that these polls at this point given
that we don't know if biden's running
and we don't know if trump is running i
don't know how much they tell us other
than
it's not obvious anybody's going to run
away with it i think that's the fair
takeaway from what we have from polling
so far if it's biden versus trump
there's a fight and either candidate
could win if it's not trump and it's
kamala harris
it's conceivable that uh either one
could win if it's not trump or biden and
instead it's for example harris desantis
as the harris pole asked
right now it's harris plus four so i
think it's too early for any of these
polls to tell us anything definitive
other than there's uncertainty about who
the candidates will be and there's a
real question mark as to
who voters would in theory rally behind
i think that we just don't know what i
want to hear from you
is do you think biden should run for
reelection let us know in a youtube
comment
find me on twitter at dpakman or on any
of our other platforms next week we'll
do a kind of reaction segment and see
what folks are thinking
one of our sponsors is blissey giving
you 30 percent off blissey offers the
nicest luxury silk pillow cases you have
ever felt on your face i've been
sleeping with blissy pillowcases at home
i have tried many pillowcases the feel
of blissey beats them all
every blissy pillow case is made with
100 percent mulberry silk they're
hypoallergenic they are just super soft
the type of silk that blissey uses stays
cool all night even after using it for
hours it's still cool and perfect i get
too hot when i sleep the cooling factor
makes a big difference the protein based
silk blissey uses is also moisture
wicking which helps if you get sweaty
while you sleep blissey has earned high
praise from a ton of publications like
good housekeeping you can read their
reviews online blissey's having a huge
mother's day sale right now giving you
30 off when you go to blissey.com
pacman and the link is down below